Wednesday but also because I know that the mats are slippery so I can't go full out
otherwise I'll lose my balance okay
okay how would you rate
the complete list of your notes so most of what I was thinking
most of what I'm seeing
oh okay okay
we are going to watch a video you can probably teach this one already but you can fast forward
if you want no as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is
your is your mark as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our
presentation so we'll start off with the accuracy first so your accuracy it's actually scored from
a four so from the
number four you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern
and then with that one any mistakes that you make with it's a minor mistake
get minus a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so I'll
let you guys know about the difference between the two so with a minor mistake
it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a powder block
six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one
for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression
of energy is also scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with
this one whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are letting do
you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that it's one thing to have a very
strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast to get uh high in that in
that category the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm when you do start your pattern it isn't
rhythm to pattern it's not just really fast all the way through it's not slow all the way through
there's a slow fast kind of aspect to it just a quick
yes
presentation is marked after right yeah yeah okay
excuse me that tickled so now let's practice reading
use plus and minus to count the errors meaning yeah i can show you okay
perfect so minor errors major errors oh i see okay you're gonna be watching your video
no pausing this time it's like a real judge and then
when you see it real time and then after the performance you're going to be reading your power
just be coordination of rhythm and expression okay perfect let's do this more
so
you're okay
power and speed